have I ever done any modeling no I'm a
little nervous about this I don't do
anything really like focus on myself so
the fact that it's gonna be about me is
a little I'm excited I get a pose with
any animals I don't know how I'm about
to take off my clothes for the camera
right now but here we go
I expect this experience to be a little
uncomfortable having somebody you do
your hair and makeup and then I have no
idea like just fashion ways what I'm
gonna look like I'm excited I'm excited
I am an Instagram model in my head so
I'm ready and you know I love me some
Beyonce so I'm ready to tap into that
part of me my usual makeup routine is
done in my car I dropped my son off at
school and then I had to work and do my
makeup at the stoplights
since I got pregnant is a lot more
minimal than it used to be I've been
dealing with a lot of like pregnancy
rosacea every time I put sunscreen on it
makes my face freak out rashes on my
face and just a ton of weird stuff going
on during the day if I'm at home splash
water on my face and ponytail or
whatever up Oh God every time a
celebrity has a baby and I look at them
afterwards I'm like no no no no no no
it's impossible I think if you're happy
if you're proud of your body go ahead
and show off but I do think they need to
tell the truth and be like yeah I had a
chef I had a trainer I got some of his
fat sucked up out of my body piles on a
lot of added pressure to get your body
back
and as you deliver basically I'm really
awkward with hosing I don't feel 100%
comfortable in front of a camera I just
want somebody to just pose me in every
photo okay help me with my facial
expression use the arms shoulders back
relax your face yeah and kind of look at
me without curling your brow yeah
you know I knew that I'd be able to pull
something off with this but I am glad
after seeing the shots that I really did
cause sometimes you envision in your
mind what you think your pictures gonna
look like and then you realize oh no I
look like a piranha but it was nice to
see the picture and see oh yes yes [ __ ]
you are snatched it was absolutely
amazing the whole process was just as so
neat getting you know my hair and makeup
done and you know just feeling
completely pampered and I feel pretty
good
surprisingly look at this hair you guys
it wasn't what I expected it was a
unique experience it takes a lot of work
and effort to look so effortless getting
my body into that position was very
unnatural and it kind of made me are my
hips hurt a little bit I have a lot more
appreciation for models I'll tell you
that I feel like I was wearing my
pregnancy like a gown the first time I
looked at myself afterwards it really
was one of those tail moments
was a pretty nice feeling like looking
at the photos after they were taken and
seeing that sexiness come through was
very interesting for me because I don't
see myself as sexy that's something that
you know you do when you're younger and
you don't have kids and you're not
married and it's like once you have kids
your mom so it was kind of cool to let
that side out and try to emulate a very
sexy woman who happens to be a mother